resuelve el siguiente problema de
aplicación usando tres ecuaciones con
tres incógnitas el cual dice el segundo
ángulo de un triángulo el 50 grados
menor que cuatro veces el primer ángulo
mientras que el tercero es 40 grados
menor que el primero encuentra las
medidas de los tres ángulos así que lo
primero que voy a hacer es dibujar aquí
a mi triángulo y va a utilizar a sus
ángulos este va a ser mi ángulo a b y c
es decir mi primero y segundo en mi
tercero y lo primero que quiero que
recordemos es que en cualquier triángulo
la suma de sus tres ángulos es 180
grados déjame ponerlo aquí a más b
tiene que ser igual a 180 grados y que
cree eso ya tenemos la primera ecuación
las otras dos las puede sacar el
problema y el problema dice el segundo
ángulo es decir 20 es 50 grados menos
que cuatro veces el primero y con color
verde lo voy a poner el segundo ángulo
de un triángulo de 50 grados menos que 4
veces el primer ángulo el segundo ángulo
es decir ven habíamos bautizado como el
segundo
grados menos que cuatro veces el primer
ángulo cuatro veces el primer ángulo es
cuatro veces y a cuatro veces hay que
quitarle 50 grados porque ve es 50
grados menos que 4 veces el primer
ángulo es decir b es igual a 4 a menos
50 ya está en lenguaje matemático y dice
el tercer ángulo es 40 grados menos que
el primero es decir se es igual al
primero menos 40 grados a menos 40
grados se es igual a menos 40 y ya tengo
tres ecuaciones y tres incógnitas por lo
tanto puedo resolver este sistema de
ecuaciones y lo primero que voy a hacer
es pasar todo lo que tenga que ver con
las variables del lado izquierdo
mientras todo lo que tenga que ver con
las constantes se va a quedar del lado
derecho entonces de estas dos voy a
pasar lo que tiene que ver con una del
otro lado de la ecuación y de la primera
me queda más de más es igual a 180 ésta
se queda tal cual la segunda dice menos
4 am voy a pasar este 4 a del otro lado
de la ecuación iba a pasar con signo
contrario es como si restar a 4 al ambos
lados de la ecuación y me quedan menos 4
ven es igual a menos 50 y en la última
voy a pasar la del otro lado de la
ecuación con signo contrario es decir
voy a restar a de ambos lados de la
ecuación y me va a quedar que menos am
aquí no tengo nada debe entonces voy a
dejar un espacio para ver más si es
igual a menos 40 menos a más es igual a
menos 40 y por lo tanto ya tengo mis
tres ecuaciones y ahora tengo que buscar
la solución y para eso date cuenta que
la primera actuación en la seis la
tercera ecuación se pueden reducir y de
hecho la primera ecuación con la segunda
ecuación también se pueden reducir si
multiplicó por una constante así que
primero voy a trabajar con las dos
primeras ecuaciones para eliminar la b y
que todo esté escrito en términos de ahí
dice para que una vez que ya esté hecho
esto puede trabajar con la tercera
ecuación así que de aquí voy a quitar
avn y para quitar a ver si te das cuenta
tengo ambas veces positivas pero con
coeficiente 1
por lo tanto basta con multiplicar
alguna de las dos ecuaciones por menos 1
así que me voy a tomar la primera
ecuación y la voy a multiplicar por
menos 1 esta de aquí entonces déjeme
escribirlo de tema
que me va a quedar menos ve y cuando
asume con vez se va a cancelar así que
déjenme ponerlo aquí la primera ecuación
la voy a multiplicar por menos 1 y que
me va a quedar menos 1 por aes menos a
menos 1 por vez menos b menos uno por
ser menos esto es igual a menos 180 y
bueno ahora voy a utilizar la segunda
ecuación que dice 4a menos 4 más b es
igual a menos 50 menos 4a más b es igual
a menos 50 y bueno pues ahora que a
sumar estas dos y no espera espera
espera de hecho déjame tomar el color
indicado para que sepas de dónde sale
cada cosa era con color verde entonces
menos 4 más b es igual a menos 50 y así
ya sabes de dónde sale cada cosa y no
nos vamos a confundir y bueno entonces
que me quedan
yo tengo menos a menos 4 a estos menos
cinco veces am después estas dos se
cancelan justo lo que quería y me queda
menos 5 menos es igual a menos 180 menos
50 que es menos 230 y ya tengo una nueva
ecuación que solamente está en términos
de am y de s
puede utilizar la tercera ecuación para
que yo pueda reducir ambas y si te das
cuenta la c se cancela luego luego así
que no te confundas hay que tener
solamente mucho cuidado esta ecuación
que tengo de azul resultó de estas dos
de estas dos que acabo de operar
mientras que la tercera no tienen nada
que ver con estas dos por lo tanto me
dan nueva información la cual voy a
ocupar ahorita para que yo pueda
despejar alguna de estas dos variables
me quedan menos a más se es igual a
menos 40 y dice vamos a reducir menos 5
a menos am pues aquí me queda menos 6 am
menos 6 a estas dos se cancelan y aquí
me queda menos 230 menos 40 esto es lo
mismo que menos 270 y bueno si yo he
vivido todo entre menos 6 voy a obtener
el valor de amd y que me queda estos dos
se cancelan y me queda que a es igual a
y bueno habrá que reducir esta fracción
que tengo aquí si te das cuenta menos
entre menos me da más pero cuánto es 270
entre 6 déjame escribirlo primero yo sé
que a va a ser igual a más porque menos
entre menos me da más 270 entre 6 vamos
a hacer
la división en 270 en 36 270 dentro 6
afuera 6 cabe cuatro veces en 27 porque
6 por 424 le restó en nuestro gran 3
bajo este 0 y 6 cabe exactamente 5 veces
en 30 45 entonces el valor de aes 45
grados justo la mitad de un ángulo recto
y bueno ya que tengo el valor de a pues
puedo obtener el valor de ese bien fácil
de esta ecuación que es igual a menos 40
pero a vale 45 entonces ya sé que se
vale 5 déjame ponerlo aquí ya obtengo el
valor de ese por la tercera ecuación ser
vale 45 menos 40 lo cual son 5 grados
ya tengo cuánto vale ya tengo cuánto
vale c a vale 45 grados se vale 5 grados
y ya con icon se puede obtener entonces
el valor de ven y para obtener el valor
de b puede utilizar tanto la primera
ecuación como la segunda ecuación porque
ambas tienen involucradas a la vez sin
embargo voy a utilizar la segunda
ecuación porque ya está despejada de
aquí la vez la b es 4 veces am 4 x 45
ahora mismo qué 90 por 2
ciento ochenta 180 grados menos 50 180
menos 50 estoy tomando esta ecuación y
es justo el valor debe que es 130 grados
ya tengo a b y c de vale 130 grados y
por lo tanto ya no puedo imaginar un
triángulo con estas dimensiones en sus
ángulos y yo los dibujo en lugar de
ponerlo aquí vamos a dibujarlo vale 45
grados es como por aquí después tengo
que ver vale 130 así que vamos a hacerlo
muy grande porque se vale 5 entonces es
un triángulo muy parecido a éste donde
vale 45 grados b vale 130 grados y se
vale solamente 5 grados pequeños 5
grados y bueno para verificar que
estamos bien sería muy bueno hacer la
comprobación con estas ecuaciones vamos
a ver si nos sale que la suma de esos
tres me da cierto 80 grados ojos y 130
cuidado cuidado cuidado y ahora sí pues
vamos a sumarlo cuánto es 45 más 135
esto es lo mismo que 50 más 130 lo cual
me da 180 la suma de dos ángulos de este
triángulo si me dan 180 como cualquier
triángulo
así que cumplen la primera ecuación
vamos a ver si cumplen también las otras
2 b es igual a 4 a menos 50 bueno esto
ya lo tenemos por construcción aquí pero
vamos a hacerlo de todas maneras b es
igual a 4 a 4 hay 180 menos 50 y esto es
perfecto estos 130 y c es igual a menos
40 y es lo que tengo aquí 45 menos 40 me
da 5 que es justo el valor de sem
acabamos de obtener la comprobación de
estas tres ecuaciones y por lo tanto lo
hemos logrado así que nos vemos en el
siguiente vídeo